oddio
oddio rose dove siamo non lo so cosa che
ha fondato due siamo rosso ma questa non
è la voce da roma questa voce da pietro
games in una voce da rosa perché sei
vestita di rosso rosa no anche la voce
da donna da donna che per i periti ros
chiamata per tutto il tempo sogno serie
per cento gala in più grazie grazie per
la 20 ragazzi minuti questo video sono
falli j sono qua con pietro per iniziare
una delle serie che volevo iniziare un
sacco di tempo ma che non abbiamo mai
avuto tempo di fare perché non avevamo
voglia realtà non c'era moglie vabbè la
prima serie che ho fatto sul mio canale
di share il gaming consisteva nel
sopravvivere insieme al mio fidato amico
che ai tempi era luca su quest'isola
abbandonata nell'oceano cioè non era
attorno non abbiamo assolutamente niente
dobbiamo sopravvivere con le nostre
forze
allora io non gioco a maida seriamente
da cinque o sei anni quindi non mi
ricordo a sfondo non mi ricordo non sono
un esperto di mycroft tipo come come
pietro ad esempio che è molto rispetto
linea quindi siamo io e lui che dobbiamo
sopravvivere su quest'isola è l'unico
modo che abbiamo per tipo mangiare robe
del genere pescare perché ovviamente le
sento di sola piccola non ci sono
animali questa roma miniera chiusa
perché ha ovviamente pietro ha preso una
mappa e abbiamo caricato questa quindi
ci sono delle cose segrete che andiamo a
scoprire nel corso di questa avventura
tipo miniera chiusa non entrare miniera
chiusa due tubazzo hazard l'azzardo
gioco gioco
e quindi niente miniera chiusa perché ci
sono i casinò 18
non sappiamo clienti thatcher kohl sotto
lo scopriremo andando avanti ma per il
resto ci sono delle cose nascoste tipo
questa che non sa di che cosa sia non lo
scopriremo più avanti avessi gara
l'unica cosa che ci promettiamo di non
toccare per prendermi perché qua è
difficilissimo trovare i materiali
quindi l'unica roba che non tocchiamo e
la nave con cui siamo arrivati perché in
teoria l'ace del legno e non possiamo
toccarlo quella barca legno veloce ti
prendono invece si pensano che è
perfetto
abbiamo due alberi quindi la prima se
vogliamo fare la casa subito no cioè
l'effetto grande facciamo la piazza ora
io faccio le fondamenta si subito cosa
che vogliamo fare è una casina piccola
perché non è che possiamo fare chissà
che cosa con occhio pieni pieni pieni i
pezzettini di albero criticano che
dobbiamo ripiantarli sono quel cazzo che
richiamano starvi sapling greco di qui
shopping che tu sei l'on
ok hai trovato b dove si fa la casa
decide no decido io
facciamo una cosa facciamo qua sopra e
facciamo due entrate una da una parte
una dall'altra un iraia potrebbe andar
peggio che potrebbe piodo piove assi di
legno e facciamo né allora né si gesù
però aspetta come vuoi farla facciamola
così guarda perfetto come mai non è così
accogliente a gesù va bene allora per
adesso facciamo così aspettiamo che
siano gli altri ne mentre bianca li
raccontando e ma ci vorrà un bel colore
e va bene frattempo andiamo in miniera
ti faccio una spada e un piccone o bene
grazie si è molto
una squadra a me ma io guardo città
marmo con la scritta eco dietro non ce
la fai
facci vogliamo andare a vedere subito
cosa c'è nelle cose degli 4 curioso bene
vai
ok innanzitutto le staccionate che c'era
non ci avviamo quelle va bene ma guarda
un po come è fatta la rientrata a
miniera al legno alle dobbiamo scassare
rispetto afferma ma no ma come scarsi
tinta zitto non prendiamo la morto zitto
zitto vero per la barca erano per la
barca della barca si è subito andato non
se n'è fatto riferendo 4 e di legno
diverso da quello che abbiamo fatto
quindi non faccio il pavimento ci faccio
parente mischiato la facciamo detto così
le falle l'hanno fatta macché ma chi il
cervello ce l'hai nella testa dentro hai
lasciato sul comodino
ma tu sei stupido ma se mi vedi che
piazzo quello scuro ma non mettere
quello che altera artistico naturale
altro legno così purtroppo non ce ne
sara mai prof
che sfiga per poco e tetti alla lan
telephony fatto di john come se letti
qua perché siccome so che tu hai
tendenze omosessuali o distaccato il
letto dall'altro la fa no no no no no
metti metti il pene nelle mutande toglie
le tre li il bene dentro con te lo
voglio vedere fuori e non maneggiare
quello birillo
facciamo una bel separa e metto qui
allora un mese pare ok pop manca bebè
bello questo è fare con la sabbia non ci
spunta non sono viste torniamo
no tra l'altro con la pioggia che ci
cade in faccia che bella dormita sono
proprio riposato mamma riecco davvero
grazie come la chiama casa nostra casa
della casa bella perfetto dove sei fuori
qui il tu non hai fiducia nelle nostre
capacità non ce l'hai che abbiamo delle
poco legno quello che siamo riusciti a
fare è fantastico quindi tu non sei
capace di dare un giudizio contro ma
loro no no non ci provare ei non farlo
no va bene da erano scrivo attendo con
finiture legno è cresciuto l'albero è
cresciuto su è cresciuto su melo aveva
piovuto tutta la notte mi chiama sono
anche madonna come se facesse tanto
dell'oro paolo ora basta per adesso
rimaniamo così andiamo a prendere
aspettiamo che gli alberi crescano nel
mentre andiamo in miniera ci sei tu lo
sai che moriremo proprio su ferro da
subito da si grande per me è una cosa
che sta spaccando con le chiamano queste
parti
dietro pietro di mogli la pietra a vieni
bava tutti muro vivo in questa galleria
giuro miniera a destra c'è del legno che
possiamo saccheggiare anche bassa che
già saccheggiato sacche mag allargando
siamo morti di fame morti di legno
occhio aspettatemi equamente line
occhiali aspetta a scendere prendiamo
più ferro va bene allora qua non serio
adesso c'è un sacco di miniere legno il
legno o mio dio cosa ho visto aiuto che
è trai 8 ahia ahia vivo sono io ho perso
questa è la questo è l'inferno allora
gesù cristo perdonami perché non ho mai
peccato nella mia vita
ok aiuto aiuto ci sono mi vorrà ci posso
credere mai mai mai mai e lì e l'isis
vai via
porca vacca c'era il nascondiglio
dell'isis sotto via madonna quanto sono
cazzute seminiere non pensavo così tanto
è piaciuto un albero legnolegno madonne
che ho suonato lo gigantesco di quelli
che c'è più legna vanno a quanto legno
c'era una storia ormai cresciuta una
quercia secolare amate mese la roba
nell'acqua crescere rivedono va bene
effettivamente non fa una piega a
giocare appena detto no mi sono fatto
malissimo
mi sono fatto di un male che madonna non
puoi capire
guarda che abbiamo già fatto la porta ne
fa tre addirittura dormiamo a bombetta
aspetta svelta per la tanto dormiamo
perché ne stoccate
sto per morire non pensa non c'è il
pivot biglietti o colpito lo stesso a
janò che sono così morta io sono così
volto in questo modo è hai per caso
studiato botanica no se per caso un
giardiniere di sempre avvisato
giardiniere
no perché perché se incredibilmente
bravo nel caso grazie
ti piace alla fine abbiamo fatto anche
abbastanza bene quasi fatti mi sento
molto più sicuro ora allora proviamo a
vedere aspetto canali calcarone è la
madonna basta scandali per indicare il
legno by mettilo ma che andiamo a vedere
come miniero noi posto è finito ok nera
un mega bro piccolo però no sono dei
sono un deficiente posso cancellare il
crafting fatto
no ho creato 44 bottoni grazie ho
buttato 44 pezzi di legno ti piacciono i
bottoni pieni thiene vi segnaliamo tutto
di bottone no volevo creare listi che ho
sbagliato ho fatto il giorno di problemi
motori
cosa cazzo saremo dei bottoni ho
sbagliato non voglio farlo apposta o li
metto tutti intorno che sembra carina
alla fine non è basta non ne sono
abbastanza nel fare altri non ci provare
è perché venga mai lasciare a casa metà
bottoni servono altri fattori bene e poi
è carino al piano di quello estetico
abbiamo ritrovato un'usanza per il 44
bottoni utili bene io ho butta tutto il
legno che volevo fare questa cosa qua
però ho sbagliato senti
andrei parti di me ho fatto questo non
so se basta basta basta
il letto che sia ma occhio che sotto
secondo me ce la prendiamo tutta neanche
a pranzi però hai una certa una cesta
una cassa no però un bottone roy prima
le signore va bene andiamo a vedere se
riusciamo a ce le loro costruito adesso
lo chiamavo visto anche prima ma non ha
dimenticato occhio aperto sulle span
span span span span span e facciamo una
fortificazione ferma perché devi fare
fronte della fortificazione
non lo so così facendo sei scemo ma sto
cercando di trovare un modo per scendere
in modo etico via degli sconti piedi no
allora questa è difficilissima tra
dell'odioso esistito occhio
ti faccio fare io mamma mia che tim ma
va bene morganti sporco alla famiglia vi
ammazzo per favore la carota è
importantissima la trota si aia vi
stanno cedendo allevamento dove la
carota con la rocca la porno e judo e
sono pronto io ma sei morto sì sono
morto io una capri ma molto giù ma che
sotto com'era una carota dov'è la però
che c'è una cesta la ayane bravo vai
presente ha premiato nicchia madonna
sempre meglio salvare il culo voleva per
farti vedere pietro stai molto bene oggi
grazie
così i fermati perdiamo casa così starò
manca la caccia lo scheletro dai davvero
non avrebbe detto guarda però a posto
c'è una cesta un diamante 3 ora non ci
credo che fini
se diana una magnifica sesto posto e poi
non so cos'altro nuova leva ferma e
bellissimo 80 di gallina che sono qui
dentro
guarda che tu ti sei accettando per
delle uova di gallina veramente era
guarda sono trovato io c'è del diamante
ma ho certo c'e nello scheletro dove sei
gore darmi una mano o caldo ma adesso di
fare le cose da solo
occhio che si esplodere utili per magari
campari norcia è un disastro
[Musica]
mica abbiamo ucciso mamma mia che bravi
anche lo so ce ne sono due ci sono due
la mia trovati jean ii noi sono 34
questo tema c'è una scala casa ce lo so
ma non esplorare ora c'è un portale del
leder watts non ci entro neanche io
andiamo prima sono troppe cose insieme
dai torneremo già vedere le cose per ora
sappiamo che siamo soddisfatti della
nostra spedizione va benissimo
ok mi chiamo il fatto lo stesso sospiro
allora tac quattro gli amanti subito
mamma mia allora io devo andare piantare
anche le carote perché sono rarissime e
ora ci abbiamo andiamo a coltivare noti
presto punto è lento mio visto che porca
vacca ricercato ha scritto lo metto
dalla parte opposta o non ti avvicinare
per montare una distanza è brutto
deficiente ma no con la terra c'è una
patata avvelenata non mangiarli non
mangiate con mangiato andiamo a dormire
vai a dormire
allora se sei stronzo porc di una
normale spero che tu muoia prima o poi
come questa cosa niente tu non dovermi
film d'amore mori io devo dormire col
cartello davanti cui dorme conoscemmo se
ti pare che deve dormire guardando
questa scritta e adesso mi esce abbiamo
messo le cose ma da quanto siamo messi
bene allora faceva la roba adesso un
recinto e metto subito i due spagnoli
gallina dentro così almeno abbiamo le
galline che ok non so che cosa avrei
fatte mi sono chiuso dentro un genere o
esatto grande che sia nata narrare
uscire senza che poi vi possono entrare
e uscire
mi chiedo se una persona con sei una
persona completamente inutile di più ma
i polli a ce l'ho io il momento della
verità ci sei dentro veneto sportivo
amico mio ti regalo questo grazie ma è
una gallina non ha sparato il pulcino
però quella grande sponda allora scopate
veloci che ci servono le uova cazzo
guardi scoperto tra di voi non a me
pietro ricorda nostrano mi guardano come
rocco guarda una sua diva e per aiuto
foggiano ma che adesso sia accorto e non
guarda 1 e 2
vai scopate di pietro chiama questo were
limone tra polli esatto fichissimo cazzo
grandi mentre lima la madonna quando
veloci e vabbè usate il condono possiamo
mamma mi chiama ci ha messo niente
una cosa quindi di quanto fanno le uova
e veloci che ho fame ma bastava lancio
di stare a caracas tripoli ma vengo ball
ammazzo tutti gli esterni
no loro ha fatto una minchiata e
successo a dire il legno perché al posto
che pare i bastoncini legno indovina
cosa ho fatto che gli sono molto bravo
che sa giocare ma va e vieni che abbiamo
bisogno di fotonica ho finito il cibo
amico sto morendo di fame
tieni grazie a verrayes sul mangiar bene
direi che possano dare spedizione
completamente da solo vado io sono
capace
occhio c'è un arciere che non c'erano
che si dice quanto pare il mibac per by
perfetto danger pericolo di non ci prova
andare li so visti mi chiama parti a
livelli ci sono le strade troppo bello
che diverte troppo non vivrete mi sto
divertendo un sacco sacco di roma miglia
diamanti altri quanti diamanti vieni
vedere dove 26 no sono sotto ecco la
madonna quante gli spazi va in prendi
tutto per colpa di non voglio avere
piccole in ferro su pubblico che abbiamo
non voglio che me la prendo io ma io
prendo io perché mi vide le
responsabilità dei diamanti della serie
che può succedere qualcosa rampi mi
rompi le palle per i che in realtà
miglio muoia così altamente si nella
lava e perdiamo i diamanti le
biblioteche se le sconfitte o mio dio
veramente è vero ma veramente si può
fare sta roba non lo sapremo mai con la
testa
anch'io ero york aiuto dovere ma che
figata
ma è bellissimo ma se io non avevo idea
bello
non si gestisce però signor pisciò si
divertino cosa ci dici una cosa più
chiusa di questo mondo non per l'aspetto
aspetta sono dei nomi passare 9999
laurel oratoria adesso c'è chi sono
questi son detto della madonna quanto
prova aiuta a mio zio che male ma
veramente o no pietro pietro pietro
piano sto morendo
madonna di passione e di passioni non
saprò mai sono morte ragas pensa non
prendendo tutto amarcord i cori pietro
abbiamo solo dei mob che fanno malissimo
prende tipo me ne sono accorto dalle
uova che sono dentro i muri tipo ci sono
i blog sono uova di silver pictures ma
sembrano veri ma che non sono gratis
madonna che brutta ma finiscono prima o
poi continua in ogni toscano
spero ha raccolto tutto se non rompere
più blocchi
abbiamo controllato tutto tranne la
scritta pericolo che sta di qua che sarà
ancora più difficile visto il casino che
mi ha trovato finora però per adesso ciò
sembra anche abbastanza cavata quindi
dire ok quindi ragazzi spero che mi ha
preceduto questa è la prima fisiologia
ufficio non è vero ti posso dare fuoco
ti prego c'è un modo per dare fuoco alla
gente però inizia per cento ragazzi come
se riusciremo mi piace anche
la descrizione che ci siete ci vediamo
con un prossimo visto bene
[Musica]